So speaking of hospitals, another 24 hours
have gone by since our initial coverage of
Donald Trump appearing at the hospital over
the weekend without Walter Reed knowing he
was going to supposedly just kind of get ahead
on his 2020 physical.
There is now more information and more context
and it's time to stop pretending that Donald
Trump was maybe not rushed to the hospital
for some kind of emergency medical service.
Hillary Clinton didn't have Parkinson's period.
That was a conspiracy theory, but Donald Trump
does appear to have had some kind of medical
incident that required him going to the hospital
when it was not planned.
If you are a Hillary Parkinson's truther,
you should be demanding transparency here
about Donald Trump's health.
We don't need to get conspiratorial.
What we knew yesterday was that Trump went
to the hospital over the weekend, spent two
hours there.
We were told he wanted to jumpstart his 2020
physical and that everything's fine.
We then found out, well Walter Reed hospital
had no idea he was coming.
We then found out that no president that we
know of has ever broken their physical into
two parts, including getting a jump on it
in the year before the physical is actually
due.
We then found out that the press, uh, was
not, uh, it was told don't expect to see Trump
at all the rest of Sunday.
The press didn't see Trump on Monday.
We have still gotten nothing more sensible
than the completely unprecedented and again,
unbelievable explanation that Trump, he had
a free weekend.
So he said, let's go do two hours of medical
testing at the hospital.
But don't let them know that we're coming.
The press Corps still had not seen Trump as
of this morning, Tuesday morning, since he
went to the hospital on Saturday.
Trump's sending some tweets during this morning,
uh, impeachment inquiry hearings.
So this is not about Trump is bad because
he had a medical incident.
I know I'm not insane.
I'm not immoral.
I'm not un-empathetic.
But the clear obfuscation about everything
has to stop.
And Trump's health is part of that.
Trump was rushed to the hospital and they're
trying to keep the explanations secret.
They are obviously not telling us the truth.
Trump has lied about his health for a long
time.
He's lied about his height and weight.
He's lied about his cardiovascular health,
claiming you know, bogus letters from doctors
saying it's all fantastic.
Now I've gotten a few emails saying, David,
this is what we've been telling you.
They are setting up either a resignation or
something that will be based on either cognitive
decline or failing health so that Trump doesn't
risk losing reelection so that Donald Trump
doesn't risk an impeachment conviction.
Maybe there's no evidence that that's what's
going on right now.
All we know is Trump is 73 he appears to be
obese, although just shy of it according to
the height and weight numbers he's given us,
although we don't believe them.
He lies about his height.
He eats terribly.
He doesn't exercise.
He might abuse uppers.
He lies about everything.
Why would we be surprised if Donald Trump
was hiding medical issues?
The country does need to know.
This is a real thing on which one might decide
to vote for one person or another.
Trump knows it.
The people around him know it and I imagine
that something is going to get out sooner
or later, but let's not pretend that this
is what Trump's press secretary Stephanie
Griffin Grisham said, which is Trump was bored.
He didn't have anything going on, so he said,
let's go to the hospital for two hours.
Even though I don't need to do this until
next year.
It's not believable.
It doesn't make sense.
Let me know what you think is going on.
Make sure that you sign up for our Thanksgiving
promo on black Friday.
We will be emailing everybody on our newsletter
with just a massive membership discount special
the last one of the year.
You need only get on our newsletter to be
notified of that on black Friday, the day
after Thanksgiving.
Go to David pakman.com sign up for the newsletter.
It takes mere seconds and then you'll get
an email next Friday.
With that info, follow me on Twitter at D
Pacman.
Let me know.
What do you believe is going on with Donald
Trump and the hospital visit and the fact
that he has as of this broadcast.
As of right now as I'm recording this, not
been seen in public since returning to the
white house on Saturday, I want to hear from
you.
Let me know on Twitter
at these Hackman, leave a YouTube comment